you walk through the market and you're
gonna see titles that you would never
imagine in your life the Cannes Film
Festival is known for big stars and big
premieres but you may not know that it
is also home to the largest film market
in the world this is the biggest market
in the world for us because it's
attached to the biggest movies festival
together with the Marche we welcome
approximately 45,000 people and 12,000
our market attendees everybody from
around the world comes to buy and sell
movies it's it's literally a marketplace
I'm from Spain from Nigeria Germany I
came from Indonesia
London the most important market for us
like with Berlin of course and for
Europe and it's really important for us
to come here every year can is the most
venerable one it attracts not only
people buying and selling movies but
it's also a family celebration for the
industry so the market becomes important
to renew a sort of the warm and fuzzy
parts of our relationship but also to
get the chance to talk about some of the
nuances of where the markets going
I personally am here to learn it's a
cram course in the entertainment
industry
so I hear for example Russia suddenly at
Roma movies coming back up in Russia for
some reason I don't know why but it's
interesting to hear it's education but
the Troma team is here to sell our
movies to find distributors and that
makes some money buyers from all over
the world are here looking at films made
by all other parts of the world to find
the right fit I think this is where it
becomes apparent that not all movies are
destined to have an audience or indeed
deserve an audience it's important for
people out there to realize that there's
a winnowing process that goes on where a
lot of people are selecting
top-quality films to present to them and
unfortunately means that some people's
dreams are dashed at a market like this
this is who we are we you know we are
not remaking is we are not sales company
we are an organisation and have been
created to serves on the street the best
as we can as we can't answer